okay this isn't good i know you have no
idea who i am i have no reason to care
but my lovely wife brenda and i got
ourselves into kind of a sticky
situation here we just wanted to go
shopping gosh darn it and now we're
trapped in here i think there are
monsters oh god this is horrible i'm so
scared not just for my life but for hers
and worst of all why does it feel so
oddly familiar okay okay gotta keep a
cool head how did this all begin it'd
been about a year since the incident uh
we don't like to talk about it
my psychiatrist tells me that after i
was kidnapped by that mysterious
international criminal organization and
kept in their clutches for 100 days it's
likely i repressed most of the memories
to avoid the trauma he told me it's an
extremely common reaction so common in
fact that even brenda can't fully
remember the exact circumstances of my
kidnapping just her immense gratitude
when the fbi brought me home eventually
we moved out of our old place too many
dark spots
into a new apartment in a different town
in a different state you know things
were good until one day we realized we
didn't have a coffee table who could
live without a coffee table these days
so we decided to make our way to the
local ikea to buy a tool store coffee
table brenda wouldn't let me go alone
she never lets me out of her sight
anymore since i was kidnapped neither of
us had been to an ikea in over a year so
naturally we found it easy to get lost
in there those warehouses are confusing
after all but this time it was different
we were lost for hours on end we even
started calling out for help but we
never got any reply and after what must
have been closing time the overhead
lights shut off well we were less than
calm about it as a day passed the two of
us stuck together we watched enough
scooby-doo cartoons in our youth to know
that splitting up to cover more ground
is the quickest way to get irreparably
lost that being said it's not like
sticking together did us any better we
kept wandering through the different
departments wondering if we passed that
lawnmower cabinet or that copying chest
of drawers before we walked until our
legs ached trying to stay strong for
each other it's impossible that we'd be
trapped in here sure i know that
warehouses can be a little over
complicated but this is ridiculous by
the time the day ended or at least by
the time the store's lights turned off
we were able to find a slatham
queen-sized bed to rest for the night
maybe we'll be able to find our way out
tomorrow how long have we been in here i
checked the date on my phone 72 hours
well of course there's no internet or
cell service in here naturally brenda
and i get up when the lights turn on and
start walking again surely anyone who
walks for long enough has to find
something right we both hold this hope
in our hearts so we pass what feels like
miles of cheap flat-pack display
furniture wondering what on earth is
going on sometimes we see figures moving
in the distance art of me can't help but
wonder if they're really there if i'm
just losing my mind in here difficult to
say it feels hyperbolic to even express
this thought but there's something oddly
frightening about the things i see out
of the corner of my eye i start to get
the sense that we're not alone in this
strange place and frighteningly i don't
know if not being alone in here is
really such a good thing at least we
have each other in here oh god oh god oh
god things just got a lot worse so
brenda and i were walking down one of
the many lattice aisles of the
kitchenware department when the lights
shut off thankfully we picked up a pair
of freyo rechargeable flashlights so
moving in the dark was no longer a deal
breaker for us goody-goody or at least
that's what i thought until we
encountered something horrific in there
look brenda said pointing into the
distance it's a member of staff i
couldn't tell you why but the second
brenda said that a chill went down my
spine it was like the lingering after
effects of some memory i couldn't recall
there was a silhouette in the distance
and in the beam of the flashlight i
could make out the faint colors of an
ikea staff member's uniform i knew right
there and then that it was time to get
the hell out of there but before i had a
chance to say anything to brenda the
so-called staff member had already
closed the distance it ran into the beam
of our flashlights its long drooping
arms and featureless face shining in the
light instinctively i threw myself into
its path to protect brenda it forced me
to the ground and began beating me with
its fists kept repeating in this kind of
freakish robotic voice the store is now
closed please exit the building if
brenda hand smashed it over the head
with a fat not stainless steel kettle
and beat it to a pulp on the ground i
would have been done for so now we know
there are monsters in here great food
and water are becoming an issue it's not
something we've needed to address until
now because of the healthy supply of
snacks in brenda's purse but there's a
hard limit to things like that we
realized we really needed to find food
in this place or we'd be doomed but
after the encounter with that monster
we're moving cautiously who knows how
many of them are still out there we
can't travel at night anymore that'll
keep us safe but it won't do anything
about our hunger situation it's only a
matter of time brenda's a genius i don't
know how i'd ever survive in this
terrible place remember i'd probably die
on day one of my own she remembered that
no ikea is complete without a little
mini cafeteria where they serve a
variety of swedish dishes including
their famous ikea meatballs all we need
to do in the otherwise sterile
environment of the ikea is follow the
smell until we found our way to sweet
meaty salvation and that's exactly what
we did eventually this plan bore fruit
and we found our way to the cafeteria
i'd never been so happy to see crappy
furniture store food we both grabbed a
bowl full of meatballs but suddenly just
before i could take a bite i felt an
overwhelming wave of nausea something
about it felt so incredibly
unsettlingly familiar what the hell was
going on here another day another
near-death experience our hearts leaped
up into our throats when we turned a
corner and saw one of those faceless
monsters just standing there the next
aisle we were ready to either square up
or run for the hills but oddly this time
it didn't even seem to register our
presence it was almost like during the
day they didn't have the same aggressive
nature to them
curiouser and curiouser just like it
said when it first attacked me i think
these things really only do attack when
the store is closed i guess that makes
them lawful evil oh god i miss dmv we're
getting a little better at the whole
freaky supernatural ikea thing brenda
figured if there are monsters out there
our best bet would be to arm up and
protect ourselves and hell i'm not gonna
disagree we scavenge different parts of
the store to make ourselves a mini ikea
armory barred full meat tenderizers
florida chef's knives with border meat
cleavers from the same set we also
picked up some fracta rope and tarplin
and a pair of stylish vardlin's travel
backpacks to carry all our new ikea swag
in in addition to the food we've been
keeping in the ikea pruda tupperware
packs with the two of us together and
all this equipment i feel like we're
ready for anything in the following week
we discovered that we were not in fact
ready for anything while what we would
later call the eight days of hell
started off rather pleasantly the
standard wandering foraging and sleeping
it ended in a no holds barred fight for
our lives when the lights turned off
unexpectedly while we were surrounded by
maybe 20 members of demonic ikea's staff
even with our weaponry we couldn't fight
many of them instead we ran for our
lives in the dark that's when brenda
tripped over a carelessly discarded
lilabo three-piece toy train set i ran
back to help her up but they were
already too close for us to make it out
of there terrified we hunkered down and
waited to die in each other's arms
that's when a series of expertly placed
gunshots rang out through the air and
the staff members collapsed onto the
ground each of their faceless heads
perfectly perforated by a well-aimed
bullet we looked up to see the face of
our savior a strange man holding a rifle
in a bulletproof vest grinning wildly
come with me if you want to live he said
and we did so we did when we woke up the
next morning after practically passing
out for this dress brenda and i saw that
we'd been shepherded into a miniature
makeshift campsite by our mysterious
well-armed good samaritan he told us
that his name was james and he'd been
trapped in what he referred to as the
infinite ikea for weeks now thankfully
he had his trusty rifle with him or he
probably would have been killed by the
staff long before now we decided out of
politeness to not ask him why he'd
brought a rifle and a bulletproof vest
into ikea in the first place we were
just happy to be alive we even gave him
a few of our tubs of meatballs as thanks
for the daring assist james told us that
there were others trapped in here some
of which have even made full settlements
with his weaponry and our supplies we
might even have a good chance of finding
others out there forming a group and
getting out and that sounded like a
great idea to brenda and i so we were
more than happy to tag along over the
next 21 days we explored more of the
infinite ikea with james it certainly
felt safer with him around being able to
take on the staff at a distance rather
than risk being overpowered and killed
in a more traditional struggle james is
a really nice guy if a little strange
during our 21 day period of searching
for others james killed a few different
staff members during the night for
brenda and i killing off attacking staff
members is a profound relief but james
he seems to take an almost perverse
pleasure in killing them but we do what
we can to overlook that fact at the end
of the day even if he is a bit of a
freaky gun nut he's a valuable asset in
a world like this however for days on
end our search for a camp was fruitless
there were supposedly a huge number of
communities inside the infinite ikea
which often have their own unique
cultures and hierarchies it was hard to
believe that all of this was actually
happening is james just making it up and
taking us for a ride but even if he was
just crazy what other options did that
leave us we just had to keep going but
nothing would prepare us for the kind of
madness we were about to face at some
point during our journey when we were
still searching for one of the supposed
outposts hidden in the depths of the
ikea we were ambushed but not by the
staff
no it was a collection of human beings
wielding knives and dressed in the
staff's clothes wearing their
hollowed-out heads like masks there were
maybe 20 of them when they got the jump
on us surrounding us and neutralizing
any advantage james's gun could have
given us these masked strangers
identified themselves of a nomadic gang
calling themselves the sons of vardhan
they'd come from an outpost that had
since fallen so at least we knew that
james was right when he told us about
the communities out there in the idea
and then something even stranger
happened one of the sons of artigan
pointed at me and said he recognized me
i said that was impossible and that i'd
never seen him before in my life he
brandished his knife and started getting
in my face claiming i was lying that's
when brenda stepped forward to defend me
as wonderful as her intention was this
just made things worse a few other
members of the sons of artigan began
ganging up on her and that i simply
couldn't abide without even thinking i
threw an impulsive punch laying out one
of the goons that turned all heads my
way and gave james an opportunity to
take his chance he turned his rifle
towards some of them and opened fire
killing several of them and scattering
the rest maybe we were better at this
whole survival thing than we thought
over the next couple of weeks we
continued our search our confidence
bolstered by our win against the sons of
article we made occasional stops
searching out cafeterias to refuel our
meatball supply you need protein in the
infinite ikea at some point during the
journey james asked brenda and me a
strange question have you ever heard of
the scp foundation while neither of us
could answer that question there was a
strange faint memory of that name was it
some kind of charity maybe a government
thing i don't know but something about
it just like so many other elements of
this impossible situation is eerily
familiar to me i just don't understand i
just don't get it and it frightens me 68
days into our confinement we found
something horrifying one of the camps
that james had alluded to earlier or at
least what was left of it the walls were
broken down and the courtyard area of
this makeshift community was littered
with corpses brenda and i were horrified
by the sight of what seemed like some
kind of massacre james just strode
forward into the camp observing the
aftermath of some unknown carnage
looks like we got here too late he said
shame a real shame james advised us to
collect any resources worth taking from
the ransacked camp and moving on no
point crying over people we never even
knew but looking at the bodies part of
me felt as though i had known these
people once perhaps in another life i
got closer to one of these deja vu
inducing bodies and noticed something
strange the body had gunshot wounds over
the next four days a nightmare erupted
after discovering the massacre at the
camp i came to realize that james
couldn't be trusted he was dangerous and
unstable and i had every reason to
believe he was the one behind all those
killers i relayed these facts to brenda
and told her that we needed to get away
from him as quickly as possible but when
we attempted to escape he caught us and
held us at gunpoint he seemed intent on
killing both of us he was bigger
stronger and better armed than the two
of us so all i could do was distract him
and hope for an opportunity to turn the
tables i asked him who he really was and
why he was here so figuring he had
nothing to lose he told us once upon a
time he had been a mobile task force
operator kind of a special ops guy for
that scp foundation
he'd been one of the best but after he
horrendously botched a mission including
intentionally murdering many civilians
over the course of his career you know
just for fun he'd been demoted to
d-class which to the best of my
knowledge seems to be a human guinea
pigs this scp foundation used for cruel
experimentation one of the experiments
they used him for was apparently this
very location the infinite ikea he'd
been in here for a long time now with
guns and ammo he'd stolen from other
foundation operatives that had been
trapped in here in a sense he loved it
in here he got to do his favorite thing
of all killing people with nothing to
stop him and now he was going to do it
to us i hugged brenda tight i was sure
this would be our last moments james
leveled the barrel of his rifle at us
and prepared the fire when two figures
emerged from the darkness behind him
holding knives and hammers it was a
woman and a large man they lunged at
james and struck him again and again and
again until he collapsed the ground
bleeding dying gone these two people
then looked up at me with a sense of
recognition and amazement and at that
moment i realized that i recognized them
too they were vicky and barry i knew
them i i'd been here before over the
next several days it all came back to me
the hundred days i'd spent in the
infinite ikea before well going on 200
days now the friends i'd made and lost
the strength i'd gained i'd never been
kidnapped that had just been a cover
story formulated by the same scp
foundation that produced that gun-toting
maniac james brenda was amazed to hear
all this and i was both amazed and
delighted to see that vicky and barry
have survived we believe that barry had
died after leading the staff away from
the encampment but as it turns out some
people are just too badass to kill my
memories were hitting me like a
high-pressure fire hose now washing away
the cobwebs and giving me a kind of
clarity that i hadn't known in an entire
year and in that glorious moment i
remembered i've gotten out of here
before i could get us all out of here
again the route was somewhere inside me
i just needed to follow it day 200 i
remembered somewhere deep down that i
needed to keep moving i let brenda vicky
and barry behind me they trusted me and
their trust would be rewarded step after
step hour after hour until eventually
we arrived light filtered through the
glass double doors a smile spread across
my face our breath quickened berry began
to tear up after all this time we'd
finally found our way out we officially
survived 200 days in ikea as we step
closer the automatic doors open as
though it was congratulating us we held
hands and stepped out into the light
together now go check out how to
actually beat scp-3000a the infinite
ikea and surviving inside
scp-3008 the infinite ikea for more
adventures from the scariest furniture
store in the multiverse